.
THE VACCINES THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATED ARE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE.
I WOULD ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO
TALK TO THEIR DOCTOR ABOUT
THEIR PERSONAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS AND CONSIDER GETTING
IT.
DICTATING IT THROUGH UNLAWFUL
MEANS IN THE SCORNFUL WAY HE
DID YESTERDAY IS NOT GOING TO
HELP.
>> Bill: SENATOR, APOLOGIZE FOR
THE INTERRUPTION.
WE'RE BALANCING TWO SIGNIFICANT
STORIES.
RON KLAIN, CHIEF OF STAFF,
RETWEETED SOMEBODY FROM MSNBC.
HE SAID IT'S THE ULTIMATE
WORKAROUND FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO REQUIRE
VACCINATIONS.
MAYBE IN A SENSE THAT'S HOW
THEY SEE IT AS YOU REFERRED TO
OSHA IN YOUR ANSWER THERE.
I WANT TO GO TO THE TALIBAN AND
TAKE YOU BACK IN TIME SIX,
SEVEN YEARS TO THE RELEASE OF
BOWE BERGDAHL.
KNOWING WHO WAS IN CHARGE OF
THE TALIBAN GOVERNMENT TODAY.
TWO SOUND BITES.
THE FIRST ONE IS FROM JUNE OF
2014.
THIS IS ANTHONY BLINKEN SAYING
THE TRADE FOR THE FIVE TALIBAN
MEMBERS FOR BOWE BERGDAHL WAS
GOING TO BE OKAY IN THE END.
HE SAID ANY THREAT THEY WOULD
POSE TO THE UNITED STATES AND
TO AMERICANS HAS BEEN
SUFFICIENTLY MITIGATED.
NOW I WANT TO PLAY A CLIP FROM
YOU FROM MARCH OF 2015, THE
NEXT YEAR.
JEN PSAKI ON FOX REACTING TO
THAT SIMILAR COMMENT.
>> WAS IT WORTH IT?
ABSOLUTELY.
WE HAVE A COMMITMENT TO OUR MEN
AND WOMEN SERVING IN OUR
MILITARY DEFENDING OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY EVERY DAY WE'LL DO
EVERYTHING TO BRING THEM HOME
IF WE CAN AND THAT'S WHAT WE
DID IN THIS CASE.
>> Bill: SIX YEARS LATER HOW DO
THOSE COMMENTS PLAY?
>> WELL, NOT VERY WELL, BILL.
AS I SAID AT THE TIME THOSE
FIVE DETAINEES AT GUANTANAMO
WERE NOT LOW LEVEL GOAT HERDERS
BUT HIGH LEVEL COMMANDERS.
WE SEE IT NOW.
ALONG WITH, FOR INSTANCE, THE
MINISTER OF INTERIOR IN CHARGE
OF SECURITY IN AFGHANISTAN WHO
IS A TERRORIST BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
THE NEW ISLAMIC EMIRATE OF
AFGHANISTAN ENCOURAGED HIS SON
TO BECOME A SUICIDE BOMBER A
FEW YEARS AGO.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE A
MODERATE, BUSINESS-LIKE TALIBAN.
YET THIS ADMINISTRATION SEEMS
MORE CONCERNED THE TALIBAN
CABINET IS FULL OF MEN AS
OPPOSED TO BEING CONCERNED IT
IS FULL OF TERRORISTS.
>> Dana: WE APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTS THIS MORNING AS WE
REFLECT ON THIS DAY BEFORE THE
20th ANNIVERSARY OF 9/11.
THIS IS REALLY REMARKABLE THAT
THIS IS WHERE WE